>>Liza: So when you're
working on projects
and you really have student-driven
lessons, it can be scary
because you don't feel like you're
in control, but you really are.
If you are planning the
right way ahead of time,
you are scaffolding every
single aspect of that lesson
and what the students are doing.
You may say to yourself, it's way
too much, there's too much to do.
But that hard work in
the beginning allows it
to be completely student-driven
and they know
that this is their education and
that I'm here to support them.
I'm not here to tell them
what they need to know.
>>Teacher: What else
can we use the lake
for besides drinking and fishing?
I want you to think about
more uses for a lake.
Keep thinking, think about
the lakes in our community.
What kinds of things do
we use our lakes for?
>>Sheela: So it's not about
just giving kids a worksheet
that the teacher has
created to complete.
It's about introducing the topic
in a way that will build curiosity.
It's about being able to provide
opportunities for kids to enquire
and ask questions around it.
It's about providing opportunities
for kids to work together
to find their own answers to
the questions that are posed,
or perhaps generate more questions.
>>Teacher: Just think for a
minute and reflect on this idea.
What is working well for your group?
>>Peggy: Teachers need to be
very conscious of building
in opportunities for reflection,
because that's the thing
that's very easy to forget.
Whether it's setting aside
the last three minutes,
whether there are benchmarks and
when you finish a particular part
of the project, you stop reflect
on what you've learned so far.
Some teachers use a class
whiteboard and as things are learned,
she stops the class and says, "Let's
all gather round for a minute.
Let's talk about the
things we've learned.
Let's reflect on this
learning so far."
>>Sheela: And then the next step
would be to really be able to engage
in discussion with their peers,
to gauge what was the thinking
from their partner or their
group members and how does
that now shape my thinking?
>>Teacher: I'm really proud to hear
how well you're working together.
>>Liza: So we have learning
targets for every day.
Sometimes the students write
them, sometimes I write them.
And I like to have them track
themselves on that learning target,
either throughout the lesson
or throughout the week,
if it's a longer learning target.
So having them do it
themselves gives them that pride
in their own education and makes them
more engaged in what you're doing.
They don't feel like, "Oh, okay,
Miss Zeller doesn't think
I'm learning anything.
I know that I'm learning something,
because I'm the one
tracking my own learning."
>>Sheela: I definitely believe that
in comparison to a traditional model,
A PBL model allows for relevant,
rigorous and responsive teaching
and learning, that
happens each and every day.